yeah and there are really good I mean
we're just talking informally in the
break there are really good
reconciliation programs and this is
where Civic Society can play a part we
were talking about the one voice
movement as well which is does actually
very good work one of the interesting
things about politics today is that some
of these issues cannot be resolved just
by governments so there's a huge role
for civic society and you know social
leadership an interesting thing about
Israel and Palestine is the one area of
where people can get on usually is the
business people right I mean it's a very
interesting thing they'll sit down a
weird getting together this big tourist
package for the Holy Land and trying to
get the Israeli tourism ministry in the
Palestinian tourism ministry to sit down
together as a nightmare we got the
Palestinian tourism business people than
the Israeli business people absolutely
that like that together because of
course they say look this is a fantastic
business opportunity look at what we can
do you know all of it you know we're
going to make a fortune is great you
know and I'm personally I think that's
that's fine i mean i'm very happy if
that happens and so actually there is a
real role for the private the voluntary
in the social sector and sees a piece a
great idea but there's other programs to
doing this could work and you know one
thing that happened to the Palestinian
vestment conference this year which is
right in the middle of the flotilla
issue as well so it's very very
sensitive that this year and last year
and at this big investment conference
for Palestine Ronnie Cohen who's
actually an English guy but a
philanthropist and business guy mean
came made a speech there and so on and
you know it's it's business people me
you know lots of in one of the things as
extraordinary is I can't tell you the
number of times you would go to one of
these Arab countries where you would
think anybody who was Jewish wouldn't be
allowed anywhere near and your fine
business guys sitting down
deals and you know the religion gets
over the religious differences go become
very quickly and as I say personally I'm
all in favor of it